one thing every stenter has in common is  the hold fast organelle which lets them  anchor to a single location now they can  swim but in an undisturbed culture only  a few stenters will be swimming freely  stunters are actually more dense than  water which means that they sink so that  hold fast organelle lets them save  energy once they find a location that  has plenty of food and oxygen but just  because they're anchored that doesn't  mean they can't move most centers are  also capable of stretching a huge amount  when attached and feeding a stentor body  can reach 5 to 10 times their original  length and that's when it starts to  resemble a trumpet which is where it  gets one of its common names the trumpet  and a molecule